the north face had been a popular
outdoor recreation brand since the late
1980s mainly focused on hiking but
recently has been very popular with high
school and college students their
hoodies and backpacks can be seen
everywhere within schools they have
changed from an outdoor recreation
convenient to more of a fashion company
so how the North Face become so popular
make sure stick around till the end to
find out welcome to Horus always so all
starting with two hiking enthusiast
husband-and-wife Douglas and Suzy
Tompkins they started off by
establishing a small mountaineering
retail store in their hometown of San
Francisco they merely serves enthusiasts
who had a passionate desire to explore
nature and soon after the Little Shop
was named The North Face named after the
coldest most intriguing side of a
mountain they describe themselves as a
high-performance climbing and backpack
retailer in 1968 the shop was relocated
to the other side of San Francisco and
the ashes are to design and manufacture
their own brand and of course they made
technical mountaineering apparel and
equipment during the 1970s north to face
really good a substantial fan base of
avid outdoor athletes this was mainly
because they sponsor a lot of
expeditions to the most remote corners
of the globe and by the early 1980s they
were expanding their product offerings
into the ski world and again they were
all about living on the edge and so they
really focused on selling an extreme ski
where and by the end of the 1980s North
Face was the only supplier the United
States who offer a comprehensive
collection of high-performance ski wear
outerwear sleeping bags and tents for
the first 20 years of the company's life
they were clearly an outdoor recreation
company but in 1990s and 2000's North
Face will become very popular with
rappers and become a staple and street
wear so what happened one of the main
reasons for this transformation was
celebrities throughout the 1990s North
Face really became very popular in New
York and the East Coast this is mainly
because north face jackets were perfect
to keep warm during
elissa outdoor activities other
performance brands are also pretty
popular within gangs and ghettos due to
their purpose but these were pretty
expensive so most of this apparel was to
learn from local stores while at first
this seems like a problem for North Face
is actually really popularized them this
made it very popular among rappers who
are from these underprivileged areas and
these rappers who were North Face on
photoshoots and music videos to reflect
the trends that were on the New York
streets and even today popular music
artists like Drake and Kanye West still
were North Face and this really drove a
lot of traffic and North Face and North
Face saw this and start offer more
street wear one of their most popular
lineups that was interest quite a while
ago the Supreme X line up is still
offered today who thought that North
Face can bar for criminal activities
would actually eventually make them
popular they also have several
collaborations with other designers and
brands like supreme in fact since 2007
North Face and Supreme have released a
collaborative part of every single
season North fate has also worked with
San Francisco's best designers over the
years to create sleeping bags and
slippers through all of these
collaborations they have really been
able to understand Street words down
they have started to incorporate leopard
prints multicolored maps and even gang
inspired bandana prints most of which
was really inspired by Supremes
signature design style similarly during
a walk nabe a Japanese designer has
collaborated with North Face every
single year since 2006 he has very
successfully merged Japanese classics
with North Face and this really
popularized art face at Japan and today
North Face is a sign of high social
status in Japan but there's an action
not a good thing at the same time as it
makes them prime targets for robberies
in Japan but in the end North Faces Weis
collaborations with other big designers
and brands have really helped them get
their name out north freeze placed
artists symbolize high status due to
high quality and of course high prices
and the fact that celebrities were
wearing North Face really just increased
the value of the brand in a public even
more what's funny is that North Face
didn't set out to become a high status
symbol the reason that they are much
more
higher prices was because they were
initially targeting at niche demographic
and this niche demographic of explorers
need a high quality products to protect
themselves from the extremes of the
wilderness and as there are not many
other choices these people would go to
North Face to buy it even though it's
much more expensive last North Face
target gained popularity it started to
become a social status symbol the fact
that it was a high quality product this
helped it even more you have to shell
out a couple hundred dollars to be able
to get a North Face jacket and backpack
and as a result this clearly showed that
you were wealthy or dumb but that's a
completely different story the reason
that it was expensive was because it was
actually expensive to design a
manufacturer and initially while sales
were consistent they were pretty low as
the niche market was pretty small as a
result they really did have to mark up
the prices in order to be able to
continue business but what they didn't
expect wasn't to become really popular
amongst celebrities and this along with
expensive price made into a high social
status symbol and due to increasing
popularity North Face did come down a
price to achieve more sales and more
volume they thought they could profit
more by selling more units at a lower
price and selling less units at a higher
price this is actually not the way to
make more profits according to
economists because as demand increases
you can increase the price and sell just
as many but I think North Face was less
worried about profits and more concerned
about getting their name out and using
this opportunity wisely and that's
exactly what they did they are still of
course very expensive but they haven't
really come down on price compared ten
years ago they actually have a good
amount of prize under $100 mark and you
can get most of their casual wear from
100 to 200 dollars and of course they
have their extreme wear like always over
$200 while this is still pretty
expensive what this does is put North
Face in a range of other sports
companies and the thing is you really
don't have to offer a good price
you just have to match your competitors
or at least come close which in this
case were mainly Nike and Adidas and
these new prices were actually within
the price range of the younger
demographic which made it really popular
among them this has really allowed them
to break into jacket and backpack market
the jacket market was previously
populated by many sports companies who
really didn't care about jackets as it
wasn't the main business so this made it
very easy for North Face to jump in
especially with their higher quality ask
for the backpack market this was a bit
harder as there were some established
players already but the higher social
status that North's pants conveyed
really helped them out during the
journey they have also tried to break
into other markets like the shoe market
but that really hasn't worked out as it
is so established already it's gonna
take a lot more than just a higher
quality product and higher social status
to be Adidas and Nike in the shoe market
but despite this mediocre entry into the
shoe market they did really really well
the jacket and backpack markets overall
North Face is very popular among the
younger demographic for three main
reasons which is popularity social class
and high quality North East makes high
quality products that are made for
extreme outdoor use like climbing Mount
Everest or exploring Alaska they are
designed to withstand extreme conditions
and this makes them really great quality
products and as for social studies
they're expensive prices doctor
high-quality materials have really made
them a symbol for high social status
they really didn't try to do this but
with hangul of politicians wearing their
clothing
it really did increase their brand value
and of course their popularity with
celebrities have really made them
popular and fashionable you really can't
go outside of winter months and not see
a North Face jacket and that's why they
are so popular but let's be real here
for a second I wouldn't say it they're a
ripoff but they are with expensive
products with huge markups but it's
really not that much higher than the
competition and they're hard quiet does
somewhat justify the higher price but
from a logical perspective if you're
actually not going to North Face gear
for extreme outdoor sports the extra
money really would benefit you and let
me just say Costco has some great stuff
but that's not going to stop you is it
now the North Face were started as a
specialized outdoor recreation brand
targeted at extreme enthusiasts as it
was started by extreme enthusiasts
themselves over the last couple of
decades they have really big
popular for many reasons a lot of which
they didn't have control over however
they did seize opportunity and used it
very wisely by maximizing our
collaborations and lowering the price to
fit more people and the fact they
actually had high quality products not
overpriced crap that sold because of
great marketing was just a plus point
and this has really worked for them over
the last decade and I think that they
will only become even more popular over
the next decade but that's all I have
for you guys on the North Face make sure
comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys liked this video the major drop a
like and consider subscribing for there
to see more videos just like this one I
told them I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one